in a year where lives have been brought
to a standstill this is the start of
what many hope will be a momentous week
in the fight against the coronavirus
this is one of the first deliveries of
the vaccine to croydon university
hospital
it's checked over as part of the safety
protocols and the first patients will be
inoculated tomorrow
in what will be the start of the biggest
immunization program
in the country's history this feels like
the beginning of the end
but of course it's a marathon not a
sprint and it will take many months for
us to vaccinate
everybody who needs vaccination hello
joseph is 90 and his wife rosemary
is 80 and both have been shielding since
the kovid 19
nightmare began they haven't got their
appointment yet
but they're hoping they'll be vaccinated
later this week
we're very happy that we've got
to a point where it's possible to have
a vaccine and an easement
of the control over your lives it's a
lifeline isn't it it's a lifeline for
everybody all the
younger people as well so it's up to us
older ones and also people that are
vulnerable to really
hopefully get it quite quickly
invitation for the jab will come from
the nhs by text
or phone call and certainly in the
beginning demand
is likely to outstrip supply the
government of course is having to deal
with two major tasks and it's going to
take a lot of bandwidth to juggle
brexit talks and the vaccine rollouts
now it's expected that eight hundred
thousand doses will be made available
this week
that's enough for four hundred thousand
people each person
will get a shot and then a booster dose
and initially
it's in hospitals like this one where
patients will first get the jab
one of 50 hubs around the country
the vaccine itself requires specialist
cold storage at minus 70 degrees
and then there's the issue of getting it
into the country but the government says
there'll be no disruption to further
deliveries
even in the event of a no deal brexit
it is undoubtedly going to be a massive
logistical
and technical challenge in the weeks and
months to come
but with the arrival of the first batch
there's real hope
that the end of the pandemic is in sight
alex rossi sky news croydon